Anytime you want to do something...
...and asking for what you want is often a big thing.
You've got to be willing to be a little terrified.
You don't have to give in to the fear, but you have to be willing to feel it.
Think of the things you'd like to do.
Ask your boss for a raise, leave the job you hate,...
...turn a work acquaintance into a friend,...
...or ask some friends to take a look at your new business opportunity.
Now, instead of saying, "I'm afraid to do one of these things,"...
...figure out how you're scaring yourself.
Make a statement that recognizes that feeling.
Your statement will be something such as,...
..."I wanna ask my boss for a raise,...
...and I scare myself by imagining he'll say no or get mad at me for asking."
Here's another example.
"I want to show my friends my new business opportunity,...
...and I scare myself by imagining that they'll think I'm only after their money."
Do you see how it works?
Acknowledge that you are creating your fear,...
...and you'll start to triumph over it.